[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente desde casa
en france 24 esta semana haremos un
repaso sobre cuál es el impacto
ambiental de los vuelos espaciales
durante el mes de julio vimos como los
multimillonarios richard branson y jeff
besos convertían en realidad él antes
lejano concepto de viajes espaciales
para la población civil
un hecho que siendo honestos es y será
imposible para la gran mayoría de la
población que no tenga varios cientos de
miles de dólares extra en la cuenta de
ahorros mientras que las implicaciones
para el futuro de la humanidad de estas
aventuras están aún por conocerse las
emisiones de gases contaminantes de
estas son una realidad
el vuelo del fundador de amazon utilizó
hidrógeno y oxígeno líquidos que son
propulsores con mucha menos huella
ambiental sin embargo el del británico
branson utilizó una mezcla de
combustible sólido llamado paul y
butadieno hidroxi terminal y óxido
nitroso la quema de esta combinación
produce co2 y hollín una sustancia negra
muy fina y grasienta unas dos terceras
partes de las emisiones de estos vuelos
suborbitales se quedan en la
estratosfera y en la mesosfera entre los
12 y los 80 kilómetros de altura una vez
emitidos se pueden quedar ahí hasta tres
años mucho más tiempo que los que emiten
los aviones comerciales en las capas más
bajas de la atmósfera el problema es que
además de contribuir a que el calor se
quede atrapado en la atmósfera
aumentando así las temperaturas de la
tierra estas emisiones pueden dañar la
fina capa de ozono que nos protege de
los dañinos rayos ultravioleta del sol
ambos lanzamientos además emitieron
vapor de agua en las distintas capas
medias de la atmósfera y aunque suene
inofensivo el vapor de agua también
actúa como un gas de efecto invernadero
sin embargo los expertos coinciden en
que aún es muy temprano para llegar
conclusiones y falta mucha investigación
para determinar su impacto a largo plazo
lo que si podemos comparar es el impacto
que tienen con respecto a los vuelos
comerciales y les adelanto que por ahora
la industria de la aviación en términos
absolutos sale mucho peor parada
mientras que en 2018 hubo 37 millones
800 mil vuelos comerciales solo se
llevaron a cabo 114 vuelos espaciales
los primeros dejaron un apabullante suma
de 900 18 millones de toneladas de co2
comparadas con las 22 mil 780 de los
segundos y aún así ninguna de estas
industrias representa más del 24 por
ciento de las emisiones totales de co2
que soltamos cada año claro que por
pasajero la cosa cambia
una persona en un vuelo por ejemplo
entre londres y nueva york puede generar
unas emisiones de entre media tonelada y
tres de co2 cada uno de los pasajeros de
estos vuelos espaciales por el contrario
puede tener una huella de entre 50 y 75
toneladas de co2 en un marco de tiempo
muy inferior lo que preocupa a algunos
científicos es que la industria del
turismo
se vuelva más popular y más asequible lo
que haría que la cantidad de gases de
efecto invernadero expulsados
directamente en las capas superiores de
la atmósfera aumentará considerablemente
de hecho virgin galactic de branson
pretende ofrecer unos 400 vuelos
espaciales al año habrá que ver qué
planes tienen tantos besos como iron
mask en estos próximos meses y años pero
según un análisis de mercado publicado
el 14 de julio el turismo espacial
podría crecer en un 17 a 15 por ciento
cada año en la próxima década
así que si por un lado se podría
reclamar que hay otras muchas
prioridades en las que estos millonarios
podrían estar invirtiendo sus fortunas
sin embargo hay muchos otros sectores
mucho más contaminantes y más
responsables de la aceleración del
calentamiento global en nuestro planeta
como lo son la producción de
electricidad y la calefacción o la
agricultura y la ganadería los
multimillonarios por su modo de vida no
son precisamente los que más puedan
enorgullecerse de su lucha contra el
cambio climático pero tanto branson como
obesos al volver de sus viajes al
espacio
y haber visto la tierra desde fuera
afirmaron que reforzarán la protección
del planeta
para mí lo más intenso fue ver la tierra
y ver la atmósfera de la tierra
cada astronauta todos los que han estado
en el espacio dicen lo mismo que les ha
cambiado y la miran y se quedan
maravillados e impactados por la tierra
y su belleza pero también por su
fragilidad y puedo dar fe de ello somos
estas cosas enanas y el planeta y la
atmósfera son tan grandes pero cuando
estás ahí arriba encima de todo aquello
que es que en realidad es increíblemente
fina es algo muy pequeño y frágil y
cuanto más nos movemos por el planeta
más la estamos dañando así que es algo
muy intenso
una cosa es reconocerlo intelectualmente
pero es algo totalmente distinto ver con
tus propios ojos lo frágil que realmente
es eso de los decentes cariverplate es
de una belleza indescriptible space
cuando vas al espacio las vistas te
dejan sin aliento o sea no hay duda de
que tenemos mucha suerte de tener este
planeta en el que vivimos annette which
we will de done y virgin garbín otras
compañías espaciales y virgin galactic
todos tenemos que hacer todo lo que esté
a nuestro alcance para ayudar a este
increíble planeta en el que vivimos y
que hoy apriete we can how test en
hardware
willy lebrón y dedicar el resto de mi
vida a ser precisamente esto y creo que
muchas otras personas que vayan al
espacio con nosotros dedicarán su vida a
hacer esto también gaste de live shake
that sólo el tiempo dirá si estos viajes
al espacio serán un problema más que
solucionar o si esta toma de conciencia
de los líderes de la carrera del turismo
espacial influirá positivamente en cómo
los países reaccionan con políticas
climáticas adecuadas a la crisis
planetaria que estamos viviendo
recuerden que pueden volver a ver todas
las emisiones de medio ambiente en la
sección de programas de nuestro sitio
web france24 puntocom
[Música]